once full podcast was so full podcast
we're back every week we're bringing you
the funny the news the daily events that
happen in our lives some of the some of
it's true some of it are made up but but
nothing's made up we got our jingle
torrents right here man all three people
what's up bro I hear chillin with our
wait 42 chillin strong I'm always 42 too
man you know the funny I'm always 40 to
30 he's a lot 14 first any shows that's
going to be tight that's going to look
like a tire a little jiggle man you
never been the same so you came back
from Mexico well your lady all happy
well whatever waist tight 38 bro loose
I'm a tight red line around the waist
tight ass 38 it's real light huh like oh
my god you were gonna lie you were
hanging on from a cliff I'm like that no
but I'm not I'm not gonna go to 40s cuz
it'll be over then I'll be like 42 and
then 44 38 yo fit into it yeah I mean
it'll be some struggle but I'll get that
button on Jimmy did you see that fool
around uh did you see that bat the hotel
which one right in Cleveland he had
those custom pants that big old fat dude
no bill around the stomach Fatty
Arbuckle
what are those pads anybody know for us
but isn't cuz when you were a suit your
pants go to your belly but when you were
old pants are supposed to go around the
back but little but mostly you guys wear
your jeans lower we've a lot of women
wear their jeans lower toward their hips
to fall on their hips but the
traditional waist is measured around
your belly button and now that you
mentioned that I don't know waist
I have great ways but I have no right my
lower flanks
so if you if your pants could like go
all the way to the top but then they
fall down just to a waist 42 yeah they
fall down well like my like ma'am like
um oh yeah well I was always 40 like my
parents can't tie up at waist 40 like
they could a good time about around my
my my ballet buddy right but it always
sliced under my stomach yeah that's kind
of shape yeah so my stomach with always
tell me about my waist 42 over here 36
down here yeah I mean it all depends on
where you're wearing pants but the true
waist your natural waist is that well
that's when you bought a pair of new
pathologies when you say no these 38:30
it's but I've been dry cleaning the 38
30s for about six months now
hell yeah but I didn't start wearing
until six months ago but I've had them
for a year they're stretchy
hell no their Levi's black tight ugh I
can see like in between the leg right
now starting to give a little bit like
it might want to tear so I might have
that in the patch should I put that
story up when you were laid down people
say down a deleted rug then like a
maniac laughing its culture the buff of
this you've got me a bad egg I catch
with a bullfrog star [__] they
will rip it to run at home brew like is
this for real
but gap really would like sitting down
at it man how do I look oh they're
getting a bad position in photos too bro
like this I got that ass right here I
did get that camera away get it farther
dawg
it isn't as a photographer you're
supposed to get good angles that fool
you're spies I don't think we can
comment there's no comments on the
YouTube what's up fool people are
commenting they're watching it I don't
know if they're able to comment I don't
see how it looks I want to make sure I'm
in a good position right here
yeah the dark stuff right here yeah we
look good I was boarding my louisa 13
shirt check you know I forgot my glasses
so I don't know if I'm gonna read these
ads these are all bad right now can't
hit the babe we got this big ol paper
over here all right let's uh let's do
this let's do this we got here upcoming
show this weekend March 23rd and 24th
Angela has a noble downtown I lay there
still ticketed for March 23rd but
they're not like I'm sitting downstairs
they're standing room only yeah there
are only single seats or you're a woman
you know who's 42 with high heels these
tickets are not for you but if you're a
man who's 20 years old I'd like to dance
it's time steel this shoulder for you
these things are for you March 24th
other plane tickets available March 30th
often texted at the Paramount Theater
March 31st Atlanta Georgia at the
Variety Playhouse April 5th Fayetteville
Arkansas a University of Kansas Arkansas
Arkansas Arkansas and man man it would
be some weird area here by know that we
get stuffed up there's a free show
a free show free to the students free to
the public if you're in Arkansas man or
near Arkansas three hours away come to
this show man I'm coming alone the only
one one hour of me so it'll just be me
April 20s 420 we're back at Albuquerque
New Mexico at Ysleta resort hopefully if
I get throwed in early I'll get to see
the town so far every time I bend I've
only seen the casino at my hotel room
main fifth turn the rally Thunder Valley
Casino in the Sacramento area Lincoln
California
everybody from weed California please
show up
lots more dates checkout flipping world
cars last tour for our shores date
taking links did you know that what's
our food is now 505 food no I didn't you
don't know sure we made it dog hell yeah
we've been waiting for this for a while
Spotify is making it easy for you to
stream this podcast and many others like
it on your mobile device desktop or
smart speakers open the app click on
browse channel and then click on the
podcast section take it wherever you go
thanks to Spotify yeah so that's how you
bro
whatever but that show DeRay Davis you
know comes Hotel it was Lisa's birthday
huh oh one of those Chavo Rita party we
just throw in a show and we ate
mushrooms no I think you did tell the in
Frisco right yeah yeah we did we stayed
in Frisco did we tell this story I don't
know if you told the story guy I do
remember you guys told me I think we
told when it started hitting me hard I
was going to peer that we had just
taking over like 20 minutes before us
and half an hour
yes well hitting me barely hitting me
and then it's a couple asked me to take
photos of them while he proposed this
yeah well but he starts taking some
photos they hand him the phone and he
started to taking some photos and I was
looking at these photos over children
they were oh I have focus and blurry
like they kept missing the shot it was
all blurry but I think it was because it
was kick him in to his vision his
perception was off you know yeah and I
said oh no give me that let me do it
better that I started doing and say it
is bad and this poor couple the guy's
hand was shaking because he was so
nervous about you know asking her to
marry him and they had a little daughter
I think it was her daughter and she was
like 6 or something like that and she
was witnessing the whole thing and they
were all happy but we had their probably
horrible older black lady and a Mexican
guy yeah they were like middle-aged like
they were all happy
well here now one movie at this bridge
of love do you take me to be your
husband the little daughter said no
mommy say no but then I took a photo I
do baby
what's off what did you propose but we
have to add do we have here one knee no
no what you do this test but how did you
I brought your detailed you give up
one-word answers here I was sitting in
the car
in the restaurant but still good a
police report buddy how do you start it
was French food yeah Renault and soberly
a bit I feel it oh no it's not Figueroa
it's right there next to intelligentsia
right there new it's a new spot it used
to be something announced back in the
day people 12p that I went there once
I've been a figure I've been defeated
with you feel it'll help duck boys wah
wah
Patti it was that's in Los Feliz right
yeah I want to if you don't want to eat
dirt yeah no nothing it's by next to but
start with a man sings out to stay alive
it's like there's a one block south of
the Dresden and there's like two palm
trees and it's very there's a cracked a
cracked sidewalk right there right next
to Starbucks and I was called feed it on
again a struggle in that way with a
struggling actor formaggio not cool or
do spray that place Dan rats but uh it
was just cool it was all casual was
another big deal no surprise that she
knew was coming
ah probably about the Rena seemed a
little bit oh it's coming oh yeah after
a rock Santa knew it was coming and as
you saw at least Salerno was coming
about the readers do now we're ago we
were at but we went into the store we
were at the outlets over there in Kazan
there and then we walked it to the store
just to look and I was like oh yeah I
like these rings I like these rings and
then Philippe I said okay we'll take
these and I was like a what
and then then the woman who started
putting him on a plane it was only like
15 1800 something like that it wasn't
that much but she started trying to put
you on a payment plan this will pay for
it payment plan for $1,500 you know have
to call the bank for something we had it
all planned out fool no so he was
spontaneous just a ring it huh would you
the ring Mexico go down there with the
Mexico City they're all they're all
jewelers and they're all Jewish but you
oh you can wheel and deal them but it's
a like the garment district you okay
yeah they have the Jewelry District
right there down the street from its
hook I don't think I like what those
guys they want cash oh it's all cash
they were cash no I mean the other
reason why I did it but if they're to is
because it's like the dollar II can
stretch it more over there yeah I'll bet
speaking of cash man I don't want to
like up chin a soldier but I J I was
doing power 106 and they asked me what
you do which we do it up if you were a
comedian and I seemed a little bit
robbed your guests downstairs you can
probably get about one or two good
rotten people says hello you better have
it here before okay of course I happened
before because you know you get these
flashy
rappers you know with Carter Kenny here
and I'm talking about like that rapper
yeah and then I saw in cash I know
they're gonna be there I know there's
gonna be some cash I'll rob them
downstairs
be a stack in a chain or comedians too
you know
but you know this stuff this is
something you would have to know if
you're a comedian that's not that you
know if you're not a comedian
I'm good ideas here to people man know
the robbers please
what happened we're asking Austria we
just he was just there what's up he said
the weed is in the silver basket
all right we're the sort of basket
I think he means this little thing this
can't be it right huh you guys do this
did you get on one knee fool know how I
got a one-meter couldn't get back up I
don't want you than I thought really I
feel I got one D she's laughing at me
would you drop the little screws that
holds your arm what are I know it's how
would you drop the little screw from
yuria Mexico yeah yeah so there's a big
jewelry Mart you do it la yeah dude
sometimes they're cheaper the same you
can get more for your money down there
and you know you know they were the
divers are either you're paying for the
name with like Tiffany's and all that
right lease or no always well that's why
the ones downtown their wholesale there
they're right there but they're divers
that you're just buying the diamond and
then you have to go by the setting with
somebody else and then have somebody put
it together for you so in the end you're
playing paying close to [__] somewhere
unless you want that one that's already
kind of made right there yeah yeah so
you can buy just the rock if you want
the coolest you can get your own setting
for it like you might have an interface
or your grandmother's old ring you know
you might want to just put like a silver
guy right next to their own place when
you get the suits will send you the tan
we're so lucky to live in Los Angeles
man like we don't how to deal with
[__] buying us through that wholesale
an idiot if you can work it like yeah
absolutely retail man like you know how
to like I understand bucks 500 bucks man
like what no matter what it hit me a
good suit I can find another store gonna
get it where Ross murasa Macy's
properties but $200 can be
I don't know but you're all you're
getting is a suit that's like the same
brand or if not better but it's just a
couple seasons behind all it is not even
that it's seasonal
no it's the same thing it's the same cut
they hire people who know how to do that
same cut that is the high fashion houses
okay are people who've worked for those
houses and then they just do the same
cut that same fabric because they had no
more oh [__] that's one of the first
things I learned in Business School when
you're buying clothes you're buying
you're paying for the label and they use
one place to make you know some of the
ones that are like exclusive fashion
house it's like they'll use one
seamstress one place one what do you
call it
manufacturer and then nudists but then
other people learn that pattern they
learn what fabric it is and they can
start generating it too or they'll cut
costs like butter I got my suit a suit
fellas right next door those two guys
the pretty American cut your suit to any
styling you want to look like 80s don't
make it you want this suits like a
hardcore 70s car we got a long coat for
you because when you got married the
place we got the suits at they have the
ones where they had like you know Calvin
Klein or like kind of name-brand then
they had the ones that were like off
Italian names and then they had the ones
that had no tab yeah Melvin Klein and
the ones with no tags it's just the same
sort of thing they just you're paying
for the label yeah these guys know a
place that can make a bunch of them my
god Hugo Boss is like in the suit like
that's like thousand bucks like my
parents I know they're Hugo Boss because
they have the red line like Hugo Boss
and then the suit has the same red line
that Hugo Boss it just doesn't say Hugo
Boss a label a supervisor it's like some
of those plays some of the food
manufacturers who make generic brands
it's the same company making it but they
make like it's like they just want to
make a little extra money you know
making generics like say for Trader
Joe's so like they'll make a little
Trader Joe's generics or whatever that
or not they don't have their label on
them but they get a cut like an after
it's sort of an aftermarket so I see you
guys should I say they're brothers they
have like Kroger like Bay yeah like the
other version of it
we're both leather pleather horrible in
YouTube lighting is not good
something like guys you look good those
little Chinese lanterns that were
outside they soften up this bags was so
fool might get another rabid dog hatches
someone left them behind brought our
bathrobe where'd you guys see this uh no
blinky some phantom ii suphannaphum a
tag me on a post from a woman in Orange
County the OSI and that's what we found
her neighbor's rabbit her neighbor had
moved and just left the rabbit behind
but just left him outside to fend for
himself and everything good yeah so so
she took him in but I was so worried
because she it was nice that she took
him in but she didn't know how to take
care of a rabbit either so it's like she
just had a bag of pellets and that's all
and like rabbits need a lot more than
that and they need attention and they
need certain things so I was trying to
help her I find a baby it's all we have
as Cheerios about milk and then
so I found a rescue volunteer near there
that can hold them till month old abate
the rabbit til Monday and they know how
to take care of rabbits so we're so
lucky and that saved some bunny rescue
org I think is their website and or save
some bunny org and they're in Orange
County and they are a non-profit if you
ever want to throw them a few bucks as a
donation they're nice but what's gonna
happen they're either gonna get along or
they're not gonna get along right or
they're like gonna be like apart from
each other they won't get along for a
little while probably after a while
gonna be like we're bunnies and they're
gone so like the operators the whole
office definitely she puts us you adieu
she's gonna like it's a rabbit's tell
people at all the rabbits this is my
turf they run around in circles to let
them know every part that their time yes
should start using the tablet what
little pause the podcast
[Laughter]
oh hey so I'm answering questions on the
chat if anybody wants to chat on YouTube
out there I'm answering questions
what's up fool but right here live man
we just got back from Cleveland man it
was 36 degrees we're staying at the
Holiday Inn clinic/hospital Hotel and we
didn't know it that we got in the car on
the way home on the way back to the
airport our driver he pretty much give
us the lowdown later on behind the
scenes history of where we're staying
and not even we were staying
we're like four blocks from the projects
and a lot of abandoned buildings and I
got abandoned factories if you guys want
to google this while we're talking we
were staying and millionaires a row in
Cleveland the old Millionaire's Row the
street that we were on Euclid Euclid
Avenue used to be called Millionaire's
Row because the whole damn street was
filled with mansions and some day all
the millionaire's moved out and the
mansion became places for homeless
people to sleep in weather were the
quarantine ounces boarding houses did
you take brother when you were like
walking around at you guessed like yeah
it looks like each to be rich yeah there
were all big old old [__] mansions
and then the other ones were big old
[__] uh it looks like a big old
mansion they got they cut into the into
the walls to make windows yeah cuz
they're all those mansions has like what
five six floors how was that barbecue
spot uh sweet sauce Williams it was bomb
dude I got rib tips how cold was Toby
man so cold my room was a hundred
degrees his room was hot oh my god I
went in there when he was wearing that
mask whoa no way that's how you wear the
back I was like oatmeal or something
dude it was hot in there filling that
mustache
[Music]
shut up - Toby Hicks and Jamal Doman
they have a podcast now the dope dealers
podcast I don't know what they goes on
but I'm if you wanna if you're a
follower of this podcast you want to
know what the hell Toby is up to you
know what they're talking about how cold
it was hell yeah
what's up for ya but I don't know how
people could keep their room or hotter
that colder hotter than 71 oh my god
even when it's cold dude I have to keep
it I like 68 because that's how germs
spread full they grow and [__] the
heat you stay there with Johnny Rocky
was that like bro for watching asleep
just clean up the restroom after you're
done whatever does hello the old ass
tennis shoes bro yeah those are like Jim
Thorpe's tennis shoes was really fun
before the [__] tennis shoes
everything music except the shoes st.
Patrick's Day in Cleveland one of the
biggest st. Patrick's Day celebrations
in America with like at least half a
million people celebrating and getting
drunk and throwing up corned beef
everywhere and we got there when it's
over but it was still a shitload of
people or never rolled it out hell yeah
people were buzzed up the show don't you
didn't see the pictures of that fools
phone like during the day yeah it was a
great dog
I taught like old school East Coast
celebrations who saw it make the order
bro nothing old-school we tell you he's
a Greek Italian he's Greek oh that's
what he is
did y'all get enough to eat oh yeah even
though he could choke food Doha and I'm
sure he's seen a couple of dudes
expiring front of them does what so
pooch these guess we have our Jay Lamont
on the show jaylen bond is gonna be on
our show are now at the Novo what are
people saying brought out my glasses
23rd the 24th what people are talking
about
what's up man if you guys like us on
like a live show some emojis dog shows
are we're happy to you're on you're
doing a show live and we get to post or
our [__] what's up for other one says
when you come into Phoenix cheers from
Houston Texas if any pair go to oh go on
Bobby Lee's podcast tiger belly that'll
be hilarious for you trying to get all
broke you must let them know and are you
ever gonna come back to Chumash casino
I'm ready to go to too much casino bro
you don't know you know me what's up
everybody
anybody who anybody who listened on
YouTube they don't know what city were
you're calling us where you're listening
from they don't know you're out there
man we're here for you guys what's up
fool we're gonna be trying out this
little bong right now the little vapor
hail vapor exhale if I could remember
how to use it
let's see what it was that guy's gonna
do he said I put it here okay shut up to
Emma right here the engineer we we
inhale or we wait and then when you're
done you pull this up and off like you
would a bomb on us and clear
what's up filter for them the filter was
out with the little great thing yeah
it's just a hole there extra water and
then this this tight isn't like garbage
Ave bong kind of like the word kind of
like the one I was making at home by
myself ever but it's different watching
oh it's connected to a core try it out
though it's like a clean here bro oh we
need some Louie yeah look legit that is
more bud what's going on here Felipe we
got a shortage yeah they say we're in a
drought this season man
what happened to Daddy fat sex where's
the so once you take it off it stops
warming up or it's already warm just cuz
your own all right has a unit in there
and this is a different kind and this
for this is poor like how bigger a
bigger bowl drip after like dabs oh oh
they say there was a gray sack bonus you
know great zipper all right and you just
come out you did put him into them out
well so you can have the other gentleman
you want to smoke like a king vape
exhale babe exhale
do you have a dog
there you go oh let him burn you are you
sure if possible hot little samples for
its there for a baby who's this for the
baby are you gonna be some Louie bro who
me if I would've known I mean I only
have one little nut left dude but you
know this is a babe exhale man we tried
it out and felt it works perfect man but
if I'll like come with the machine is
awesome if anyone wants to get it at the
vape exhale if you had some solid at
Bo's and I would suggest having more
weed
so now right now I felt like we were
hitting some buddies we on the road I
got one nug in the truck gonna go get it
up go check out both cool rad dogs well
do her come back here cuz your ass a
birthday yeah I don't know the man
Rodrigo man he's like a Carlos sewer of
marijuana like right you don't
understand like this guy he's picky with
him marijuana like if like if you come
up with him with a blunt and it's skinny
he walks away he goes you know what man
I'm gonna go count just merge money I
gotta go
he leaves he don't stick around and
sometimes Toby Higgs he shows up you
know from somewhere and he has his weed
yeah I just got their eighth for $40 and
they were judo goes man $40 man I ain't
gonna be good and he says very good but
we're all high I don't know I guess some
people like caviar
and some people like tuna me I like both
your back dog is not smoke at all I need
so for the head yeah
no choice good do it show us here we go
break it up so later gentlemen that's a
babe exhale if you wanna dream look for
it okay the new web series Internet
check it out it works it's a clean hit
and they like car when you when you
light it with a match and it's rough you
know yeah and involved and my listeners
get 10% off on the vapor exhale evil
ever Evo a vaporizer and not other vapor
exhale products by using promo code foe
that's F Oh Oh L at vape exhale calm
there's nothing else out to let the mo
get big bang for your buck or the ever
it takes way less to get you there the
taste is phenomenal tell you man but you
don't even let that your bird just took
it all lid
hold it now what's up J love - huh
better make it actually whistle I say
god he's not gonna see like a bagpipe
shoutout to the beep exhale we're live
right now davon on YouTube by the way
youtube.com slash ATC definitely give me
one of these please oh man every every
improv green room to have one of these
bro
somebody called Robert Marvin every
every umbra here Lisa will need no
backwoods after this let me load another
one Ethel
so you're gonna give them rope this is
cash to did well so fool what's up
everybody listening out there you know
no I know we're trying out the same
thing and all that good stuff
I don't forget to use fol and get
yourself a little discount on this thing
these hot hot we're gonna witness
Philippe his skills at breaking new box
I could bring balls what's up everybody
we're chili man with we're gonna
remember a long time about 20 guys that
I bought on Tyra Banks having a crush on
somebody this is the genic Russia no
Tommy chant oh yeah and then Gabriel
Tommy what's up fool you gotta wait for
it to heat up so it can be used with
both floods also get also math not to
mention the taste is phenomenally so
what it say it like clean green clean
green okay it tonight no paper it is
really no backward it a like no match
it's actually about my back lids
okay you got back was rolling skills
don't know where you learn whatever when
I'm not there it can be used with both
flour to dab dab it grandma you can put
it up you can put your oils on it like
if you get some good Moxie or so good um
some good oil man it's on it's on Brazil
what paper
exhale CEO sell bull shed is a former
stuntman and backup dancer and now uses
cannabis in his Brazilian Jujitsu prices
and we might have over here man yeah
maybe you might teach auto grab someone
and grapple hold and did
yes sorry indirect still wait for a
bomb-ass sable is a huge advocate for
normalizing cannabis use in today's
society use promo code fool at vape
exhale calm that's VAP e ex h al e com1
full podcast is brought you by the
people who said you ain't gonna be [__]
what's up everybody
you're gonna be [__] man you mumbling
and fool nobody understand you and do
comedy
who said I said it to myself oh don't
say that those hair to myself he will
say that oh but they want they I met
Willie Barcena he said dog you gotta
stuff your mouth with paper bro and talk
dog to be the Corleone bro
you were some Willie Barcena bros going
on bro sitting here rest in my eye bro
what's up fool we got Jay Lamont on the
shoulder damage a limo Johnny Jay love
my ass he's gonna be with us at the Nova
theatres October October 23rd is it
October yeah okay I'll come back in
October
hell yeah man what's up what's though J
levonne are you doing man the jailer
mummy or the boys like Tom Jordan it's
good to see you what it's after the hour
we've got much more on the way you know
Tom's a good friend I've been hearing
you on Tom Joyner man oh yeah man yes
dad man how you been
do it was the first time you saw jr.
milah with Def Jam are you solving
person Casa latina
I remember that no man we talked about
we talked about like calm when I had
that room wild coyotes yeah and them
Edwin's rooms we talk about our and then
we every time roughly made what the
death the the late rough for me yeah we
will always talk about oh man if I'm
ready for the mescal rooms I would never
eat yeah commit mescal real paid yeah so
you do a lot of rooms are like at the
east side for us huh
man I did a lot of those little Gilbert
Esquivel I met you guys you already use
the mansion
yeah Sebastian oh you guys man y'all
showed me so much love I can't I can't
thank you enough
king of the Acapulco and you were on a
pilot right we'll keep her Iglesias and
Tommy Chunn I'm for Jimmie Foxx
it was Deez Nuts yeah oh I forgot about
that yes yes that was like oh that was
like 19 years ago I remember Gary Lester
was telling us 2001 heroes tell us yeah
Gabriel tickets to eat after every every
week they pay Gabriel I saw those 10 G's
yeah he was going it was sort of into
that gear would tell us so many inside
stories like what time mom he goes one
time mom how was this anyway so why her
one time Gabriel Cato telling her that
no Tommy Chunn we're all hanging I was
talking ringing I was Tommy Chunn uh-huh
and we're hey you know Gabriel right but
not at the same time
yeah so they will give us insight stuff
and every time we trusted that he will
Gabriel was always late
Gabriel s yes oh wow he was sleeping on
the set and now and then our what Ted
they're watching Gabriel I know they
were showing the sketches and they were
showing Gabriel and then Tommy Chunn
said to Jamie Foxx yeah man [__]
he can't even fit in his group he goes
he was a too big to be on the screen
he's gonna be out no no [__] but Tommy
Chong's stand up he could he to beat me
he's bigger than the screen and Jamie
Foxx said nah man he'll be out two three
thank you for inspiring them oh wow
are you serious yeah
how was that man the whole working I let
your first pilot that was the first
pilot I did for Jamie I've known Jamie
for years yeah for that man
so we go way back and it was so funny
because I remember one of the days at
the studio whoever I don't know I guess
whenever somebody was coming to see
Jamie he would send someone to come get
me and I thought I was in trouble
yeah j-jane about yeah Jamie won't see
right quick ten minutes later Jay jamie
foxx want to see right quick so whoever
was coming by to see him he would want
to show me off a man me my man there's
my man like Jay to my mate give a little
some guitar dude Peary so I had to do
all of it I'm thinking okay did I do
something wrong no no Josh just got my
new top box we're gonna be rocking the
house down by you you should go through
an east of the river bro we got the
[Laughter]
first book east of the river
that we have mosquito on the show and I
do it a little here - I'm an ax Mad Max
didn't have a good name is easy why yeah
I don't know they were like a big group
like collected like outcasts or yeah or
the other guys had a nine and a DJ had
to ordinary tackles another way we have
we have a vegan food bringing other
people you know vegan Tino's finish last
some beef in there something just for me
just we sit
[Music]
quality music you guys want to order but
we're providing front well friends of
ours begat enos which we've never met
with your friends online every ticket
sold you know actually that was kind of
a condition yeah man the whole world
[Music]
sold I'll be dug well we had a deal of
money will go no not me I'm so glad you
were none of your available eggs I was
excited if I am bothered me I don't care
you us they don't all pay like this oh
my lord you work with with what's in
them right thank aya be sure to get your
dick Charlie Wilson the gap go remember
the gap Baker Charlie yeah I've done a
couple of days ago but then when you do
music I do it all so the type of show
that I do like was a gap right now oh
yeah I've done that for him he knows
that I do that so when he saw my show he
said I got to have this guy open up for
me so I do a lot of Casso even if I'm
not doing a comedy show I'm doing
concerts cuz they like that stuff that I
do
so just to do it in front of her like
20,000 who we ran into at the airport I
think we run into at the airport one
time and you were with him oh we flee
where was this this might be no cuz I've
been with him all over Austin Texas we
probably did we probably did yeah cuz I
mean I've traveled all over with him you
know and I'm gonna be with him next
month in San Diego so you guys come
check me out San Diego without Charlie
we're gonna be at the big one the
outside theater
yeah no Valley View Valley Casino sooner
okay be a hot show yeah check that was
my there no no the kid bro
like and then like come and I would
whenever were doing that video in the
better the beach that one he was doing
that song look at oh yeah black a black
bikini with cowboy boots cowboy and he
would crack up if he saw that video he's
like oh Lord I remember back then I
thought it was cool it was no homo for
me more like alright it [__]
gonna give a [__] but better speech is
like that that's you will represent me
because there's food that was still
walking around with a bikini yeah dude
[__] I out they shot a video on the
beach the gap Bell was two guys right no
three brothers with Charlie and his
older and younger brother yeah Charlie
Robert and agrees to blast love those
gaps and we're all from the same state
was that Oklahoma where Oklahoma that's
one from Oklahoma City they're from
Tulsa straight from Roger truck players
yeah another German that I that I've
told I've actually travel was that as
well I grew up with diamond Williams's
daughter Shelly no it's cool but there's
so much funk I didn't know get it was
from Oklahoma yeah a lot of fun not just
countries Parliament
you know who else I worked with us from
Oklahoma Color Me badd remember Oklahoma
City went to high school one of the guys
yeah are you so oh yeah oh yeah we
represent yes not just country there's
code me bad song
[Music]
I adore me amore dream on dream there
from Oklahoma City color me bad oh yeah
so uh you were you made you made that
your debutante Def Jam right I actually
might the first TV show that I appeared
on was actually Showtime at the Apollo
Apollo then I did BET's comicview move
on you were a guest your amateur no they
I was a guest they booked me on the show
right but you know what but they but
they always say even if you're a book to
guess they can do they can do you too
I've been of those shows they're people
I can't wait
they boot singers on there who was
booked somebody told me store where
Luther Vandross the first time he went
to the Apollo they booed him and his
career just soared Lauryn Hill got
booted one time her career source
Japanese chilling up there shooting at
boots
she went nowhere anybody who surprises
the audience that they're really good
they get and I was scared stiff when I
went out there and they they loved me I
got a standing ovation I was so honored
I was I was amazed and they asked me to
come back and do it two years later and
then it was comedy when DL Hughley was
hosting the first host of comedy and
then Def Jam oh yeah yeah my did Def Jam
twice when Joe Torre was the host never
got to do in mark cuz I wanted to work
with Martin you know but later years
later I did a show that he produced
called a first-amendment I think you did
that didn't you do that show no First
Amendment standard I didn't do that one
oh I think just I think I did I'm just
joking or he got jokes with Kevin oh
yeah yeah I remember that one I'm BMT
yeah I did another one on Showtime no
one on a Comedy Central with jb smooth
yeah but I'm proud you Phillipe I just
got to say I'm proud of you man
I remember the time we first met and I'm
like this man has seen he has soared and
here we are man and I'm just honored man
to be on the same stage with you
Felipe Esparza it shows are gonna be so
good you okay you guys are getting a
hell of a show for this
in Purgatorio Feeny hey two of people
yeah yeah Kendall Feeny bro
hey you do it mr. Dumont you the way you
do it alright I'm doing fine yo bro I
could do Obama you know I'm stage it's
an honor to be here standing here with
Felipe Esparza Thank You Felipe for
inviting me I know not the president
anymore
many people have missed me in there's no
way up that I'm gonna go back to that
White House we are going to turn this
mother out this week he's got like three
different voices though he does it's not
just at one level you know like Obama
you can do an impression and that's just
one what prior ideas he's got like three
everybody always does a turn so bad
getting a rose Julie how did you figure
out that you could do this like what
started you doing this I was a kid seven
eight years old playing around listening
to the radio whatever I saw on TV I
would just mimic the sounds would drive
my mom crazy something you know all the
time she was age boy shut up shut up
come on wash hands food is ready but as
I got into the business once I told her
I want to do this as a profession of
course she thought are you serious and
then she would call you know we need
soon you know we got to get the bill
paid uh-huh
how much you gonna send baby how much
you're gonna say
yeah your dad was a talk - yeah yeah you
say you don't send us that money
remember that time we told you to shut
up
well Lord you know my dad was a preacher
believe it or not anything hallelujah
praise the Lord you're gonna send us
some money
Oh remember when mom and I told you to
shut up well we want you to open up your
mouth have a much day right on that
check
you may call every noise you can son and
he'll god bless you click couldn't get a
word in edgewise no both my parents are
deceased
well your mom got me last year right
yeah my mother passed away in 2013 my
dad died in 2011 Tory's yeah well what
was crazy I was on tour doing shows when
both of them passed away so that was
really tough because I couldn't get
right home you know to my family so and
the worst feeling is having to get on
stage to still do the show right before
you can get home to bury your parents
not a great feeling it was tough to
write songs yeah we had my myself one of
this this women who opened for Felipe
she came down to do a show with Felipe
the day her dad died and she still did
it and she'd want to go but she got a
ratatouille and he you know she was like
I have to go and it was a really
emotional day but she did really well
and like she opened up to the crowd and
that was the greatest pain cuz I you
know in our business you know there's no
such thing as paid leave or take a take
a sick leave you I had to do the show
cuz I needed the money part of the money
that I made when my father died was was
a help me to help them as far as my
travel expenses cuz I didn't have any
money and even though the promoter said
hey man I'm so sorry man don't worry
about coming to the show I said no I'll
be there I'll be there I've got to do
the show and it was really tough but I
handled it yes I did
I got a microphone so you can hear all
this microphone over there
he's microphone follow me there's this
hilarious I'm enjoying this shake it has
smoke right here
you don't smoke no I'm I've got a
contact already I feel the spirit when
you were you were a kid right one
pleased that Kenny became all right yeah
the first one oh you know I remember
slow for the show for white shadow ha he
did do that one right
remember that one of the creepiest
episode did see an episode and I said
wait a minute looks like mine was low
Michael where's low would like a bomb he
let go he was like up either a bar boy
on the show yeah or he real young a gym
manager
yeah I'll control the towel and I fear
not bully and a loner and they were
talking to him and one of they gotta be
friends him yeah does this crazy scene
where he's in front of the mirror and he
does all the characters and his creepy
yeah as far what's this called I forgot
about basketball coaching or what was it
coach Reeves one of my favorite shows
when I was in Middle School
oh yeah hey man did you see white shadow
last night yeah man that was good yeah
Freddie boom boom Washington was on that
show too
they won't touch of some serious
soldiers later there was one well there
was one episode where with where the guy
named Gomez he let the Mexican guy
Coolidge you know salami he's made in
the name of the high school but it's
based in LA here in LA
Carter hi Carter hi or car behind behind
and then like then that could love that
show didn't show jump the shark Brody
more all the time singing in the shower
I wish they could bring that back you
know what it was so funny because MBA TV
show that for a while waiters business
in the episode hey buddy who oh he
played that DJ they proposed together
song phrase your Smith did you say
fraser-smith he just never know nobody
oh right yeah I knew I knew about that
all but I loved him
beautiful Fraser was he the one who
always I remember when my mom saw
something he didn't I'm telling you boys
remember that I love you
hear the funny jokes was bad yeah the
calling back spinach today the good
title beautiful [__] out of Popeye I
don't know why was next to Joe deal when
I heard that joke had a heart attack I
just see them grow okay coca blood came
out of it no that's right almost like
Fred Sanford there hey pop won't you dig
yourself you know what the biggest oh
man too numerous to mention Steve Harvey
oh yeah John Witherspoon bang bang bang
I loved him
oh it's so many man who all have I
worked with as far as yo Steve said the
Entertainer cause you know say it and I
we all started together pretty good get
it back that show man that was Jimmy
fire with terror bags in it yes she was
crush on you
I had a cry I think I had more of a
crush on her but I wish she would have
had a crush on total that she had a
crush on you she told you religious oh
well I think well you know chubby chaser
I think cuz I know what Thomas was there
alibi was on the set as well as a Darrel
heat remember Darrel Hill and they told
Tyra about me so they said J saying
something to Tyra and I remember singing
an Isley Brothers song would you say and
she started screaming I was throwing in
between the sheets no mystery so she's
doing all this
what you know about that as far as I can
see I wanna keep you here and I think
she's gonna grab me and do something to
me I wanted her to go ahead but you
broke oh but she hugged me she hugged me
and I melted oh the first year I had to
call my mom that day call my mom
I meant time cuz she loves time what
she's my mom
I'm thinking that soon he got me he got
me having moments now oh my god oh do we
have commercial breaks on here she's
tall right
very tall yeah she was tall cuz I
remember I think at the time we had
there was a lunch break and she was
getting ready to go get some get
something to eat
and she invited me to come with her
because Alex and Darryl got in the car
wish yeah I think she had a Mercedes or
something at the time she's like you
want to come with us and I think I had
something to do I don't know what it was
I was mad I said you have a lot ago but
can they get out can you get Darryl
analysis there and let me go with you
she was nice man she smelled good I do
know that okay I beer has oh nice he
wants everything I held her Felipe I
held it and she held me and she was in a
pilot as the performer she was number
one I was gonna be one of her cast mates
Wow we saw the we saw the pilot man and
man I had to give our time each other
knee when you were played they play Redd
Foxx they got you because you could do a
bunch of voices right yeah Jamie Jamie
actually suggested me to be a part of
the show he was working you guys were
hard real I wouldn't say it's a you know
I wouldn't say he was working as hard
but you know we had to get certain
scenes right and stuff like that to each
other and it was another guy on the show
- that did sound effects kind of like me
so they kind of paired us up oh yeah was
that girl hey there with trumpets cuz
there was there was a bit there was a
skip we did where Jamie was coming out
and we were like human jukeboxes so he
would do a little something that I would
do something and so Jamie's like you'll
turn me sour because if I was switching
the radio
oh so good Emma started moving around
but that was that was a good experience
that was a lot of fun they're literally
the best how when you're working you're
having fun you're getting paid well yes
I mean Gabriel stood over like $10,000 a
week well over him but that's good money
like I'll take that oh man you missed
that [__] why would you do it you show
up on time of course or you fall asleep
on her in the park
Gabriel was a soldier no man could that
man was doing shows in our lay at night
and still driving to San Diego to be
with a girlfriend and then driving
foreigner in the morning to get to
Jeremy parks or dedicate a nap at lunch
just dedicated dedicated man yeah a lot
of people ask I could do that job really
it is just performing [__]
he's a being there and it's being alive
to the show right cuz there's so many
people who want to invite you to go to
stuff I think I said nah man going how
much how many people invite you to go to
stuff at the end of the show
not too many anymore they don't want to
talk to it won't invite me nowhere I
guess I guess I was or nothing
Rodrigo man could make a t-shirt or how
many cans grab him like that I know the
greatest moment was when we were invited
to a Will Smith party and that was a
great moment it was out in Burbank Jada
Pinkett Oh God Jada wasn't that this one
I think this was before Will and Jada
got married Will Smith was there I saw
will I'm looking around me along I think
she was there I don't know so many
people were there
Nick Nick Cannon cuz I've known Nick for
years we first met in Atlanta and he was
there and he came up and came up and
gave me a hug and at the time I think he
was dating somebody I can't remember who
it was but oh my god that was a great
moment
I was just melting looking at although
excuse me the women yes have you ever
been a regular at The Comedy Store The
Improv Laugh Factory or it'll play ice
house you never never never not so you
were like you just went from performing
to working all the time they're not
working all the time you know whoever
would have a show it like some of those
spots tourists mmm did the Def Jam tour
twice which was a lot of fun because
what was cool about that
that meet myself and kid Capri we would
do a mix of hit Capri when when I look
my age to do my set I look over kick kid
you ready to do something you know he's
at the turn and then I'll get on the mic
about the print it was so much fun and
they loved what I was doing so will you
ever let you know like you weren't going
on we ever in like a beatbox group you
know when you were younger like a rap
group with joining a meatball contest
never never did a beat ball cut beatbox
contest look there was a guy that I was
paired I used to actually be in a group
it was me and another guy who did sound
effects so we would do little shows
around Oklahoma when I was in college so
I would do like we would do cameo word
up we would do candy or other songs and
he would do like the bass the bass sound
and I would do all the other instrument
sounds mix it up the crowd was going
crazy like oh my god you know so that's
probably the only thing and and also I
do sing I sing profession I've seen you
yeah so I've got an EP out right now so
on iTunes and CD Baby and I have a band
I have my own band so I saw you what I
don't know what kind of festival was but
it was like music in the park uh-huh you
were doing I just said you were doing
mic check with your friends oh yeah you
saw you spied on me up I mean what let
me watch this guy man let me watch him
no this is a group that's the group that
I sang with I you've got to see this
group oh yeah it's called shells juke
joint you were thinking of song oh the
song you're singing I was doing I think
I think I know the clip you're talking
we were doing a I think it was no no I
think it was Aaron Neville I think was
doing Aaron Neville tell it like it is
oh that's right yeah and and that oak
that entire group were acapella we do
our own sound effects and that's why
they that's why they brought me into the
group
[Music]
gotta get warmed up for this week you
think they'll like all of that oh yeah
forget about it that's funny like Carmen
there'll be a good ass show how the him
Gabriel I said that Paula for a sick you
could do their own cartoon without a
[__] cast oh I'm Stewart he got
Gabriel glass yes Jayla bar Apollo
Francisco alive his own show on the same
show you don't need to cast nobody else
Oh voices that's Jimi Hendrix a part of
us is gonna be a one-man one desire
Pollock doesn't never I Aaron Neville
bid because he work with her and Neville
oh did he yeah and Apollo I want to
Aaron this did you do everybody does
they like Aaron Neville mo talking oh
yeah how did he do it bro he talks about
it's a piece of Tory soul yeah cuz I
never even knew who what's name was
Aaron Neville but I've all heard his
brother I never had a group his family
group yeah Neville Brothers and one of
the right yeah yeah yeah yeah big hit
and he I know he's done a couple of
other songs too and then one of his
brothers one of his brothers used to
play in a group called the meters all
the meters they had some funky cuts back
on a day broke it was a sign for basil
slash don't get supper Callie
[Laughter]
you know what I like yeah yeah they at
Euro a why I'll do that this weekend I'm
gonna mix it up planted Rob will put
some Lisa listen called Jam is a
comedian up there and he brought up you
know I met Lisa Lisa once when I was
working in radio I was a DJ in Houston
Texas she was real nice cuz I don't know
she was doing a show down there way so
i'ma do a little bit of her planet rock
so we'll pull it will pull it all out it
up do you do you mix it up knowing your
stuff oh yeah
back and forth you know we'll slide it
some don't do any of that new stuff it's
got like the auto-tune in it like
imagine having a conversation
don't you feel you in this man said
Peter Frampton who was first Peter
Frampton or Roger and Roger actually
acknowledged have you heard him do it on
Donny he was very he still was telling
me that like nobody in Bates and really
give a [__] but they were still walk
around their fur coats well he was my
school one time cuz he when he was
rapping Shelly Murdoch right I know sure
he had he had her as an artist on his
label and she was performing and he was
on the show and he was trying to was
right after his two hits and he was he
started but this was after his his solo
ones that oh yeah I want to be a man
okay computer but then he was walking
around our school in his fur coat and
this was like June it was hot hilarious
beginning of June he was passed in the
rickets you gotta do it at that man one
once you know you made your success for
it that's the Jesus that we're happy
with what you're doing you know yeah my
report of course somebody gave me one
right oh he was I mean he was like would
you work on some Gators and walk around
the neighborhood sure Roger kinda around
the neighborhood though cuz he and his
brother they own her they get a lot back
to the community which was really great
yeah and they had Troutman studios which
was two buildings on opposite corners
and I think one of them's eventually had
a Church's Chicken pop up next to it and
they were just kind of going so well but
then they when he got killed and his
brother kill himself then they all the
grass was growing up in the
creet like they just weren't taking care
of it anymore it was a blight on the
neighborhood but it was we produced a
lot of work around there a lot of stars
came in Roger Roger was one of the first
artists that I one of the first music
artists that I opened for to do the
stuff that I did because he saw what I
was doing and even up up to now when I
work with them I'm good friends with
Terry Troutman his brother Terry and
Lester the drummer they're still running
and yeah the last time I worked with
them we were in Atlanta did an outdoor
venue
Zapp Shirley Murdock think mint
condition was on the show how many weeks
out of the year oh man so you're a busy
man with hard to get hold of you uh
you're probably more busier than I am
Felipe you know but that's that's that's
the thing about this business that's the
life you know we're doing out of a smile
we do nothing with it my own I don't
know where I'm gonna be Thunder Valley
Casino well if you need me let me know
how are ya
what's the date and I'm not doing
anything whenever you like the song
we're doing more casinos and I like the
spinners say yes or no mm temptation
movie best movie ever
the one or five heartbeats or Jackson
fire oh my god that was number as far as
like real [__] like I would have to say
liberation is better give you the chills
my little nephew Esau - he fell in love
with it there was a lot of drama going
on in that group you know they lost many
members they have so many you know any
of the guy that the original guys Jeremy
no Dennis Edwards who just passed away
Wow friends with him he replaced wasn't
them replaced David Ruffin yeah who they
who they actually fired from the group
you know it was a lot of sadness was his
voice is a one of the ruling
yeah he had that preacher sound you know
sir I can turn the gray sky blue I can
make it rain whatever won't you oh no
the first time I taste some funny the
first time I met dentist was I was
working at a comedy club in st. Louis
and he was in the audience I didn't know
it and I actually was I was doing a bit
that involved Dennis Edwards and just
giving him honor and the host said you
know Dennis is sitting in the crowd he
wants to meet you I said I didn't know
he was out there so Dennis walks up to
me Matt ball come here that's how you
talk welcome to let me get your hook boy
I like you and I remember one time they
did a show they did a concert because
you know they had different temptations
groups his was called Dennis Edwards and
the temptations review because you know
he and Otis had separate groups Otis
Williams the other original member he
was one of the founding members and I
remember they did a show at Disneyland
so we went to go see them there and it
was so all man was amazing amazing but
rest in peace Dennis Edwards that was in
the movie when there was two temptations
yeah and yeah that kind of like come
nowadays there's two wars right there's
war and then there's lowrider lowrider
band that's right Teairra which it was
the one brother with the other brother
because of silence brother broke up that
is crazy how that you know when it with
us that's how it is you can't get along
I'm a strong no we'll do the same songs
but different that's just how we're
gonna break up with a love mods and a
Jake what do you call the group when
you're together yeah it could be that
well my band will the band that place
for me or has played for me is known as
what they went by the name of one blue
shoe and black top and most of those
guys oh no trust me no no it was a great
concept I had explained it to you but no
some of the guys one of the guys in the
group is my producer or my EP we went to
college together he's from Oklahoma City
also a lot of talent from Oklahoma and
of course most of us live in California
now so who would at home
so you didn't know Charlie Wilson the
gap came from Oklahoma no matter what
that's how that's where the gap goes
there's three major trees no no no
there's three there's three major
streets right near where they grew up in
the in the the black neighborhood of
Tulsa greenwood archer and pine street
so when they formed their band when the
out of high school in college it was
actually called the greenwood archer and
Pine Street bands and the guy that came
in to manage the group he's like you
know what we got to change that that's
too long why don't we just use the
initials the gap band they'd be like
okay you know what that makes sense so
that's that's what that's how that came
about north Tulsa Oklahoma
Waymon tinsdale NBA star you know rest
in peace he's from Tulsa Oklahoma played
played in the NBA played for University
of Oklahoma
well people saying about our dilemma
somebody asked they said it's great
sounds just like zapped players Aaron
Neville is great that's why ash my boys
wasn't strong so I couldn't really do it
and then somebody wanted to see if you
could do Vaughn Mason
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my favorite movie about coming to
America
[Music]
Arsenio from coming to America as the
preacher you know I love the long I'm
sitting here with brother Felipe god
bless you there's women all around
ladies I want you to stand up and turn
around slowly
see that's God God when you go home to
your lady Felipe say god I don't know
what you what
besides being with us this Friday
Saturday we're all working actually
after I leave you guys I'm going a
Sunday this Sunday I'll be in the Bay
Area Pleasanton California Tommy - OH
with my friend Dennis Gaxiola
oh oh I'm gonna tell you know that was
Tommy out those doing Dennis do Tommy
again
no Tommy's kind of like man what's going
on yeah I've got Tommy T's then I'll be
in Las Vegas
April 2nd doing a tribute to Marvin Gaye
you know April seconds his birthday when
he was shot you know his dad shot he was
shot on April Fool's there
so I'm doing a tribute for his sister
she's coordinating this show so April
2nd Las Vegas and then Juan Diego April
14th with Charlie Wilson so he didn't do
to do the Marvin Gaye yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna yeah no comedy on this I'm just
gonna sing cuz she heard me actually
saying and so I'm gonna do some Marvin
Gaye songs with a live band got they're
gonna have a live band everything it's
gonna be nice sister heard me sing of
Marvin Gaye song actually was a song
that she loved and she almost cried and
she said I got to have you saying it at
the tribute I'm doing for my brother I
remember when Marvin died I heard it on
the radio and it was it was April 1st
and I ran down to tell my mother because
she was a huge Marvin Gaye Tammi Terrell
fan yeah and I ran down to tell my
mother and she did she thought I was
joking because it was April everybody
did not believe everybody and then we
heard on the news that she was just
bawling that night it shock comfort her
I was I was in high school at the time I
remember that day funny cuz there was on
a Sunday we had just gotten out of
church me and my mom and just so
happened I when I turned the radio on
they were playing let's get it on and
and I remember the song was fading out
and the DJ came on talking slow for
those of you that just tuned in if you
haven't heard the news
tragedies just struck Marvin Gaye is
dead and me and my mom like what did he
say Marvin Gaye's dad he was shot and
killed we'll have more details coming up
in a week we couldn't believe it because
the even some of our teachers at school
thought it was a joke yeah April Fool's
joke yeah what's up with all that [__]
why did he kill his son there was the
word there was a lot of Spector well you
know it had been said for a long time
that well he and his dad didn't really
get along no man they didn't have a good
relationship and in a situation happened
where they got into an argument you know
they said dad was argued with his mom
Marvin was at the house at the time and
I guess apparently didn't like the way
his dad was talking to his mom and
somehow they just got into a scuffle dad
went got the gun and shot him
damn basically so it's funny you took
your own child that's funny
like I guess I have my own theory how
like shot or I believe someone else who
told me he said that he I just kept
saying now bro Marvin was all cracked
out brother blood look at that started
ass that's the kind of story I heard
that's why I told it well Marvin huh
he always had problems with painkillers
and while he was trying to fix his stage
fright
that was how it all started try taking
pills that way and then he just got hurt
about this in that movie jungle fever
when Simon Jackson gets shot by his
father his father yeah homage yeah
Marvin Gaye yep
man that was a hard scene to know the
hardest evening no steno yeah because I
know I mean I've been a crack in myself
but my brother is that crackhead yeah I
want to so jovial [__] hardcore
conman thief but your mother still had a
big heart for him because he has a
little dance three and he used that
dance for everything for my mom come on
mom
right I really $30 it was and what's
crazy about this a notice that the
father said the dad said well since she
won't get out since you won't get out
I'll put you out yeah that's just how he
put him a magic older like for real yeah
when you got the pistol I like jungle
fever and the soundtrack at score he did
the score for the songs on its
soundtrack yes water up Stevie Wonder I
just want to say this what I'm so
grateful to thank you for the love that
you've given me you know just thank you
to Philippe and to everyone at all for a
bit sure I hope that I'll get a chance
to open up the show so wonderful that
for you to give the blessing to the left
to everybody out there so thank you for
that shout out there please Shh you yeah
give some Shaq yeah
I don't know what I'll do I must start
off with Ernie Johnson and we're back
live inside the NBA tnt force we've got
your Kenny Smith we've got Charles
Barkley and right here we have Shaq Shaq
what do you think about the games that
we just saw so far
Charles what about you well first of all
first of all let me tell you some you
know the worst team the first word you
know the bad team they can't play the
team suck but let me tell you something
let me tell you something I think I
think people make it to the playoffs you
know but let me tell you some you know
he always says it let me taste I first
of all first of all they're no good they
should have fired the coat they
shouldn't fire not fire but fire on
coach because wouldn't coach fault but
but first of all but let me tell you
something let me tell you some Shaq Shaq
your notes tumba they don't know what
they do they can't play what's up magic
[Laughter]
magic is smile I just got to talk about
Larry Bird and how great it was back in
the day I was playing LeBron James and
Kobe see we learnt about comparisons to
gether
but we were friends yeah it doesn't
matter what you think you can do it
drinking game first of all first of all
when I play when I first made magic it
was like magic these are these are the
guys there that I and you know admire in
mind before but liberté something like
magic Kareem they were great players you
know players Jayne were they big game
Jayne
first of all but let me tell you let me
tell you something I don't know what it
is up so I keep saying it but first of
all magic responded to magic an ad for
zip recruiter here so to break in here
zip recruiter and music and do the music
babe are you hiring are you posting your
position to job sites and then waiting
and waiting for the right people to see
it tricep recruiter
this time zip computer build a platform
that finds the right job candidate for
you Zipporah learns what you're looking
for
identifies people with the right
experience and invite them to apply for
your job in fact 80% of employers who
post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day 80% the right candidates
are out there
zip recruiters it's how you find them
right now my listeners can try it
zip recruiters for free that's right
free go to zero guru comm / full f o l
that's dipper cooler that comes flat
full zip recruiters comm / fool the
smartest way to hire you know a lot of
people out there money might think in
yourself a man I don't me really need
the recruiter but you do bro you know
man you might just have a lot of plans
you know that any trimming and you're
tired of hiring your friends you're
tired of having a home being your turkey
recommendation from a friend you know
you're tired of hiring out of works with
rappers or other work punk rock work
work punk rock singers you know look it
against Jerry O'Neill point out you want
to hire the right people man so zip
recruiter will weed out don't [__]
wack ass fools bro no weed out anybody
that has a dream you know you don't want
to hire someone that still has hopes you
know what I mean you want to hire
somebody with no dream somebody this is
going to work get paid come by my you
know a lot of people out they want to go
to home after the after after their job
and these are the people they look for
man real people man
real 905 people and I don't know my how
people do it no I'm like let the cook at
the hilarities uh every night bro go
take out the trash smoke a cigarette
come back in get on his bike and drive
away home and then with that with a
little dinner for his wife in him like
damn that's his life that's people's
life huh yeah he was a definitely a dude
that had a job it would do his job
like he does his job leaves with a
little treat you don't see that like
well I don't see it because you're my
stand-up comedian brochet I go home I
don't have a home I go to a [__] dirty
ass room no oh and you're out of town
it's funny my like when wanna tell bro
like I think about eating chips and like
I don't even look at the trash I just
drop it on the floor why not I mean you
ain't gonna pick it up how's he doing
Toby Hayes oh my god my dude I don't ask
up in here I love Toby it's funny man
Heello
you know you know used to traveling so
much yeah things I used to like Tom the
discomfort that comes flying United or
American yeah so I don't know he just
appears my he'd having like I'm more
than you doing here in the morning yeah
to try and deal with flying yeah yeah
BAM beer right and there Toby Hicks
please come to the gate
Toby Higgs wait they have to page him
Wow
please far so when I think I text him
I'm like for the college you remember
the headphones on drinking the beer but
I did but the hotel's calling him I've
like imitating his boys being loud for
the strangers but I just ordered my beer
he came with his beer ha yeah he left
the bar and came with his beer and they
wanted him to uh exchange his seat and
give it to him this couple that had a
baby
he said no
I paid for that seat him you know did he
give it up cuz all they had left was
middle seats and then you got to pay for
all the other seats so that's how they
get you at these these airlines okay so
you think it's one price but it's really
not it's gonna be like forty dollars
more for a side for a regular seat you
can even pay for middle seats on some of
these places they charge you the middle
middle seat yeah so yeah I got my first
class the way I wished I could I forgot
what it felt like to fly first class
I don't Michael black steel flat first
glad I'm thinking he's skinny anywhere
he sits it's gonna be you might as a guy
fly first class might a second where you
Marissa you ever work with him many
times
yeah any times love Michael that's my
buddy you still jump on those tours over
with a big tour with comedian like
Rickey smiley every once in a while
every once in a while hey well huh the
man it pretty good pretty decent I mean
you know I was able to pay my sprint B I
think that was about it but I'm trying
to think what was the last major
comedian that I worked with it might
have been I think it was I don't
remember you know but it'll come to me
Mike s been a while yeah Mike Mike and I
want to get a few times you've worked
with Mike yep Katt Williams surprisingly
I've opened for him a few times you know
just had a birthday
Felipe put him on phone that's that's my
girl right there give me $20
luenell use a burning bag og go Bernie
Bernie come on come on go back to sleep
burning back another great legend oh man
you ever performing him see him perform
never perform with him but I met him
once we actually met in Columbia South
Carolina and I was we were both in town
during the show I was at a club on the
other side of town he was at one of the
main theatres that I actually played
that later on but we met backstage real
nice guys i chained him are you doing
brother yeah good to meet you man and it
was so amazing he gives back to because
this lady came back with her son who
wanted to meet Bernie Mac and so he said
how you doing young man you're doing all
right
what grade are you in and he says he
said I'm in such a great he's like
you're doing good in school he pulled
out a hundred dollar bill I gave it to
him you know I read an article on GQ
abou about Bernie Mac and it was like
this big article about about urban
comedy mm-hm you know the black circuit
chitlin circuit whatever circuit yeah
but they were showing how big it is
right and they were showing like how
much income Bernie Mac brings into the
town not just put on a show
yeah whatever the comedy joke though
comedy show the comedy show but how much
income is put it brings the N like
people buy suits right yeah not only is
he like he's good for the city's helping
the economy he's no they're not only
buying a ticket but they're spending
money eating at these restaurants yeah
and you know man black people get
dressed [__] you were right right all
right I'm very much about how we love
was allowed to certainly advance we well
we have to be that's an important the
black right stupid but you know what it
did it started though because years ago
because black people had to go above and
beyond to fit in to feel like they fit
in to social events where there were
other non black people like white people
looking you know too late he wanted to
make sure they've all of her family
looks straight you know we're together
you know because they still didn't get
respect so no matter you know and I'm
running there for my day cuz
they're being a minister you know I
noticed the times we would go out
somewhere he would always dress nice
sometimes we would go to the we were
just going to the bank and he'd have a
suit on he said son you got to look nice
you gotta look at they're gonna look
presentable you want to make people know
that you're important just like anybody
else about how you dress you know that
was a big deal so he brought in all this
money man like parking lots valet
everybody noticed you know like you know
everybody everybody makes money and
legit him right and um he said that he
was in Vegas one night and Redd Foxx was
headlining I guess mm-hmm can he just
walk to a tree see I'm I'm a comedian
too and ever if I say while you're next
Wow I will [__] in my pants but you know
next yeah he threw a minor and I was
like it's like Redd Foxx Wow yeah that's
a moment right there but Bernie Mac you
know you he was killing it in Chicago I
heard from people that he was destroying
could we had wasn't him here man Ali
Leroi Ali Ali yeah I know Ali yeah yeah
Bernie was a man he was a genius such a
genius gone too soon
but I hate I never got a chance to work
with him but like I said that one moment
we made into South Carolina that was a
great moment great moment so you have
that groupies coming around Wow that's a
question I've never been asked honestly
you're a bit behind a girl now do
Richard now do Bill Cosby that has
happened a few times now dude honestly
on the ring and how do the dice man most
times they would want me to sing to them
impression when I was saying the
president is saying I remember times
even in high school I would have liked
when I would do talent shows though if
there was a girl that liked me you know
she would call me at home and she'll say
Jay sing to my this my friend sandy we
used to sing to her and she'll click
over and have her on the other line
listen there we go
maybe owners screaming going on that's
what I'm gonna call you back you know
then a girl the girl that likes me she's
getting jealous cuz the other girls
screaming at me and everything like that
yeah yeah that's my play we're gonna do
some later tonight okay where your house
okay we'll go with my brother locked up
in a playpen no house my play what will
your house okay because it's good that
was a term that was in our who is my
play cousin
I never asked we teach it to the other
ten the greatest night isn't that the
greatest bit did you [__] believe you
can get drunk off of sweetie oh my god
yes mmm
like diabetes yeah of course I can't
drink it all the time but it is good
that's why I say we have iced tea Sun
tea but that's different yeah senior in
the south in that region it's like every
place you go is like do you want sweet
on sweet that's that's yes when you
order iced tea they'll say sweet or
unsweet he says you won't hear that out
here yeah I didn't have
have us more - Alisa Wow more bro yeah
he didn't know and none of your nephews
then we had your nephews over and we
were roasting they never had a s'more
they were like 13 14 they were have
monkeys either well that went into his
axe anyway well I gave that monkey bread
recipe I brought all the Ohio stuff oh
that's good bread we had open enough for
my calves they had all the time it was
like it was a butter buttermilk cake or
something at that we gotta wrap it up
all right wrap it up it was but it was a
chest cake Chesky yeah chest cake it was
like it was almost like a cheesecake
sort of thing but it was like a dance
I just love red velvet just give me a
slice of red velvet I'm in heaven the
first time I had red velvet mmm why I
never have red velvet right - older when
it went through Lee's barbecue in San
Antonio oh wow Rudy barbecues the [__]
but out I was a saint had a red barber
Kate with the zingers the red one they
were like their version made there
well no no the zingers yeah they have
yellow they have chocolate the three the
red one with the red that's weird ballet
so that was super sweet you wrap it up
wrap it up what do you want to take us
out with something somebody because I
was so [__] uh war
Michael taxis from this program
sponsored in part by
get away the nude Cologne that gets that
funk away spray it all over on sale now
knowledge your outlets exhale exhale
exhale breathing oh yo take it all
everywhere you go give them Cheech and
Chong
my old man teaches on s ol work I got to
work on them you got me on that and I
love them how about Michael Jackson
[Music]
that's good
[Laughter]
[Music]
Taman Jay Lamont and I'm Jay my Facebook
Twitter Instagram next under you're
gonna be uh this Sunday the 25th Tommy T
is in Pleasanton I'm a tea but then I
got a dole ah yeah April 2nd I'm in Las
Vegas and then April 14th San Diego
Charlie Wilson it's talking to you is
that a tickets available oh yeah they
can get tickets there you can buy them
online I think go to Tommy T's calm and
what's the webpage to be bought at rage
and the name of the place in Las Vegas
where am I in Las Vegas somebody did ask
that what's the name of the place it's
called it's called Oh what is the name
of it okay uh okay I don't know oh it's
on my page it's on my people check that
I also matter I didn't mention look and
I am gonna be at the Thunder Valley
Casino on Cinco DeMayo and that she's
already gonna be sold out man so oh it's
gonna be a Lincoln is its own Lincoln
California near
mento taking they're going fast like an
hour thousand fifty tickets and we're at
384 so we're at forty percent food oh
yeah yeah the place in Las Vegas
backstage bar and billiards oh yeah
that's a bar that's well that's where
we're gonna be yeah I've been there
before
yeah so it's the Marvin Gaye tribute
show downtown Las Vegas really so okay
so I'm okay I'm looking at whose table
okay so that's where we will be what
stop for you thank you very much
everybody Frankie Carrillo show up ready
career Freddy's if Frankie Freddy
Edwards in Las Vegas to it you that
probably Hollywood oh really
actually actually had a residency
therefore really you did have a revenue
see like just more short two years ago
at the Flamingo yes yeah didn't last too
long but it was it was a great
experience that's good man yeah I'll
take it yeah I'll take advantage of it
let it easy money it'll be on my bio
stay tuned next for news